my wife was invited to talk at some
meeting decades ago and the topic was
the 16th 16th dynasty in ancient Egypt
and she was you know saw this
announcement and she was thrilled and
then she discovered she was the one
speaking this is no good because nobody
knows anything about the sixteenth
dynasty so you know don't know which
child turned out to the eighteenth she
doesn't know something about that and I
look around the room and I see premio
why don't you talk you probably have
something to say laughter Peter also
marks verbatim okay so for the record
that was a bad joke and now we get on so
the tar the topic I gave Dennison said
as little as I could think how to say
cryptography and computer-security the
view from 2016 which means I you know
give you as much as I can get away with
of how we got here a little bit about
where we are a little better where we're
going so that's anyone who wants to walk
out can get a head start on the mob um
you know cryptography originates in two
places with our kindy about 200 a H and
Baghdad and with Albert II Porter and
some other people about 1500 AD in Rome
and there's lots of details of that but
from a cryptographic not cryptanalytic
point of view it comes sort of up to two
to two things right they figured out
what was wrong with what they knew how
to do is that you get to see the same
construction to many different contexts
if you're substituting you if you
replace H with Q and then you see the
cipher texts of the words th e and WH o
and so forth
you get to see get several views of it
that's called depth and that allows you
to to recover what the substitution was
and then this was all analyzed to death
you know in 1945 and 1949 by by Shannon
and he's a very famous part of
of cryptography what they figured out
was he that the main thing that came out
of those things what's called a
polyalphabetic cipher that is to say you
change the way in which you encrypt with
every character thus you encrypt so
people don't get to get a real good look
at it and as you know that is cooked
down in the current form in which you
you know add add a bit to each bit that
you're sending and either flip it or
don't with a 50% possibility um the way
they critical point in my mind is you
can make a reasonable argument that
symmetric cryptography has not changed
in 500 years hours hours coming from the
European tradition the the Bagdad papers
seem to have been lost until sometime in
the last 20 years or so they're
discovered and al-kindi is getting a lot
more credit these days but homework
problem anyone who can trace a
connection presumably via the Crusades
from middle-eastern cryptography to
European cryptography would have a very
good thesis topic so that you know
basically all the systems have two
things they have table lookup and they
have some kind of arithmetic so in some
sense what's called a visionnaire cipher
visionary wasn't really the inventor
visionnaire was the vp of marketing but
he got his name on the cipher what is
called a visionary cipher which goes
along with a sequence of cipher
alphabets I look up tables and goes
around in a ring of some length or other
substituting four characters is except
for size and complexity the same thing
as the Advanced Encryption standard or
has built on the same principles mass
encryption standard has a has a lookup
table it's a bit larger it has some
underlying fancier mathematics start up
by keyser Nyberg
in in Finland and it has arithmetic in
this case is the arithmetic of Galois
field
and some simple sort of XOR arithmetic
but it's not a huge amount new Under the
Sun just took a lot time to get to it
and the other point is nobody can do
those Visionnaire type things very well
by hand so in principle you can build a
secure one but you have to do it several
times and if you fire do it several
times by hand you make some efficient
number of mistakes so you never get any
messages through
so until we era of good enough machining
to make mechanical and electromechanical
devices that did it there wasn't much
action in that direction the other
possibility is to encrypt more stuff at
a time so you back grab a big chunk of
it now the possibilities about that the
one that got used for five hundred years
of all codes you pick the objects that
are significant and you have possibly I
think there was us code there's a
hundred thousand million entries so it's
somewhat like a normal Dictionary of
English and you substitute things now
you have analyses you can do about how
long you can use it before you've done
it too much and she ought to change it
things of that kind and that governed
cryptography up until two great events
of early 20th century first is the
invention of radio it's early 2019 o3
when the first transatlantic radio
message is sent and that just changed
everything
all of a sudden there was this wonderful
thing that nobody could plan to stay in
business and refused to use that was
pretty much open to everybody listening
to it you know eleven years later they
start fighting in the next big war and
it's the first war fought in the Euro of
radio and it just bypassed all of the
information security technology of 19th
century and they knew how Locker
safes and guard their offices and things
like that and now all of a sudden
there's this transmission the only thing
you have is cryptography
and it had two properties it wasn't very
very secure and it wasn't very fast but
it was all they had and so they they did
that and the inventors got started
working and the inventors came up with a
couple of different things the most
famous one is called rotor machines and
the first solid rotor invention is in
Auckland man named Hebert shortly after
that our people named Serbia sand dam
who laid the foundation for the most
famous enigma machine called famous
river machine called the enigma and that
was sort of the backbone of world war ii
cryptography lots of other things were
done but lots and lots of traffic was
sent in and in rotor machines yes I mean
if you're counting you know how much
cryptography is you can count three
things how many pieces of equipment how
much money was spent for them or how
much traffic was processed they aren't
always the same thing and then of course
the deal is cleared a little bit by
trying to figure out how to compare two
things one of which is more secure than
the other one so at one time you know
one time the Zenith TV scrambler was the
most widespread cryptographic device in
the world if you want to count it as a
cryptographic device somebody reasonably
Snoddy might not today its SSL in the
browsers far as I can't find anything
for which I find a larger number account
and it must compete pretty well on a
number of bits shipped I don't know
about total cost so the that technology
the rotor systems probably the fanciest
of them as an American device called C
GABA which has ten rotors but they don't
all process traffic five of them tell
the other five rotors how to move
anybody doesn't know rotor machine does
index table lookups you have
instructions on some machines we've had
around here that do this you have a
table and you know you have an indirect
address through the table
and you have a an index and so what the
rotor machine does has just changed its
index one character of the other it
changes the indexes and it keeps looking
things up in the tables well see GABA
had one rotor machine that tells the
other rotor machine how to move a lot
more complex and enigma had I had a one
up counter like an odometer accountant
but all of this has a very serious some
very serious disadvantages
one is what's about slow 10 later maybe
15 characters a second that's that's
just fine you know that was the speed of
teletypes at that time but versus a
minimum of 120 characters a second
formulated that way and so what happened
that was tremendously important and ver
had this one's going to rank high in
money low and traffic bought odel
traffic volume and in the fairly - say
data rate and low in the number of
machines it is called sig Sally and sig
Sally was a secure telephone in
remarkably similar to a current secure
telephone will fit on your desk except
they had occupied a room the size it
occupied thirty seven foot tall racks of
equipment wait about thirty tons and I
memory cost about as many million
dollars and initially they were just a
couple of them they only only Churchill
and Roosevelt could afford them right
there was one for the cabinet war rooms
except it was in the basement of
Selfridges in London and there was
another one somewhere in Washington I
don't think it was in the White House
and these things had most of it of
course the crypto system is rather
simple crypto system is what's called
one time you have a 16 inch which is the
professional standard long playing
record and it has binary informational
and XOR is bits with the with the
plaintext and at the end of the
conversation the code clerks smashed the
record so it can't accidentally be used
again
but most of its of ochres right so a
vocoder but now of course goes on a chip
at that time occupied most of 30 racks
of 11
well that wasn't eventually all the
four-star generals has jumped up and
down demanded one there were dozen or so
at the end of the thirties but what this
did was show everybody the prospect of a
new way of communicating and that's
that's I think that's one of the
dominant things if you look at this we
look at some of the later cases that the
important thing is people want to
communicate in modes that are made
attractive by other things in voice in
TV in an email in Facebook you get
instructions that you didn't have before
eventually it's going to dominate
virtual reality and so the 50s one side
of the 50s in cryptography was dominated
with producing faster and faster devices
that are what I call long cycle systems
you have something of known period
typically a shift register and then you
do something to make the output of that
register nonlinear and there are two
possibilities and you can either you
have what's called a combiner you have
an into one function that produces
outputs the combined places in the shift
register or you have you apply you a
combiner as a predicate and use it to
stutter the shift register so the Ridgid
register moves an irregular number of
places justin said that's overall that
produces a better sequence but on the
other hand has the big disadvantage that
somebody might detect that you're doing
more work to produce some bits than
others poor creature who came out of
this the school figured that one out in
a more modern context and what's called
differential power analysis something
like that and now to my mind the most
interesting thing that happened in the
early 50s is very separate there was a
project see I don't know what you guys
know about radar
was largely developed at MIT and was
called the radiation laboratory
intentionally misleading renamed in
World War two it was what was in my era
it was building 20 but the radiation
laboratory itself closed I think in
September 45 but in some sense was moved
a block or two something that the Air
Force Cambridge Research Center opened
and didn't have as many people up some
people found other jobs but it went on
then for another 30 years and it played
the initial role in what was called sage
the semi-automatic ground environment
which automated the activities of people
who sat on radars and looked for
airplanes and called up anti-aircraft
guns and said said shoot that thing and
that's very hard to do by hand for
something of the size of the United
States I tried to watch see if
anything's coming in and so stage was a
major a major business one could say
because nobody of course it was never
tried right never it was never used
thing or nobody ever attacked us with
conventional aircraft over those routes
and so nobody knows how it worked or not
I thought it was Nora a system that's
affected Santa Claus I thought Santa
Claus had too much stealth to be found
by sage but maybe and maybe you know yes
we detected it it just happens to me in
the next room by name seven even and one
interesting I learned from studying the
history of this is this is what made IBM
you know I didn't understand at the time
that the IBM 704 709 709 Oh we'll all
built basically for this project let's
go a little further back this is
wonderful I mean all computers built up
to that time things like the johniac and
the maniac and so forth were all meant
used for scientific calculation for
example they did the h-bomb calculations
on some of these machines and they did
them by checkpointing every aid
two cards so the thing ran for months
working on this calculation but it
didn't have to be reliable all right you
mostly lose on average four hours work
if breaks at some point you fix it you
load from the previous cards and you
started again well a guy in Forrester
at MIT had this dream of using it for
things like air traffic control and so
he Nia's machine to be reliable and that
turned out one that was really expensive
things were literally gold-plated less
corrosion and he was about to get his
ass thrown right out right when somebody
whose names of my mind at the moment
basic from the Air Force came along and
was looking for you know had this notion
of air defense and as the book put it
and suddenly the objective changed from
avoiding air collisions to arranging
them and that was a much more profitable
business and IBM was the one company
that showed enthusiasm for this and it
paid for the cost of generating the
first big you know the generations the
the thing that made IBM the company was
more than half the market well yeah at
AFC RC there were two products two
projects and I can't get them entirely
sorted out yet the one is a data link
project because there are no motives
weren't than what they are now and there
were radars out somewhere and there were
big computers somewhere and there's a
fan-like network bringing data into the
computers and has to be transmitted
somehow and some of it comes from
aircraft somewhere it goes to air craft
lots of it comes from ground radars and
so they needed the I call the call I
think we call it imodium but they go
data link and those terms still used in
the military the system is called this
some of the data link 11 data link 16 I
think are big things now the other one
is the identification Friend or Foe
problem where were to into after World
War two you know you have a
control radar sees an aircraft and sends
a message saying you know respond
correctly or I'm going to tell the gun
to shoot at you and all of that world
war 2 was done by BAE analog techniques
delay lines and you have a you chased a
signal when you shuffle it around by
delaying different pieces of it
different amounts of time just
incidentally 2.9 microseconds is a very
important unit in those delay lines
that's because an order was sent out in
42 or 43 for fazil microseconds and it
came back and it was wrong it was 2.9
and there wasn't time to make them do it
over again and so we're still we still
have 2.9 microseconds we probably have
more serious legacy problems in our
technology at any event Horst I still
worked for one of these groups and I'm
not perfectly clear at this point which
and Horst he had emigrated from Germany
in the mid 30s went to MIT and then he
went to Harvard and he in January 30 oh
yeah he was about to become a citizen
when the war started and so he's put
under house arrest and that not
literally but if he went went over to
new from what Boston to New York to see
his aunt he had to tell us case officer
and things like that and then January
31st 1944 he got his American
citizenship and the next day he got his
top-secret clearance and he went to work
at the radiation lab they've been
watching him and he had never been in
students it was a child and much
I mean Plessy major in physics he's
really a stirrer in cryptography and he
says people at the lab said to him
during the war
it's not the time for a German to be
talking about cryptography Horst
but after the war he discovered a system
I think he must have been in the data
link room and he discovered a system
moving through the IFF group and what
gross history what evolved there are two
aspects of digital iff one is a thing
that's now ubiquitous you used around
the world call the mark 10 so mark 9 is
the last analogue of the mark attends a
digital one sends back you know you get
challenged by the radar you send back a
number in the case of civilian aircraft
this is just basically something loosely
speaking the flight number may be more
to it than that but not much the mark 12
made arrangement for encrypting that and
so in comes a 32-bit challenge and back
goes four bytes or something of
encrypted scripted challenge incident
there's format so funny and I'm not
perfectly clear I need to study a bit to
know how to translate them into modern
data terms so don't don't take those
numbers too seriously
but you can't do that with a long cycle
system it has no inter symbol defense
dependence I get always ins encrypts the
same thing the same way or you have to
add a large indicator or something like
that you need something that encrypts a
block of digits and they begin working
on that problem and somebody had
designed the system and horst just was
incensed they hadn't been adequately
avout evaluated and his group got their
hands on it and worked and sure enough
they broke it and it was debugged by a
number of people and then they broke it
again and that hadn't been fielded yet
they had been was just on the verge of
being adopted formally for this purpose
eventually that system was developed
called Cadmus I don't know if that exact
one is still in use in the eye after
four slices there was another one later
called mascar but the that is now at the
root of in particular the the first US
public cryptographic system the US data
encryption standard horsefly still
basically had people to support him for
a while I mean the
that lab @f crc closed he went Lincoln
labs and unless I see dreams if that's
not his name same as the department
store in London nope Harlan suffered
suffered I was Oliver Selfridge
supported him for a while at at Lincoln
lab and then he went to mitre and he was
there for a little while and he got his
crypto work that shut down then he went
to IBM which you know for whom the
government was merely was not their
owner so to speak it was merely a good
customer and beginning in the late 60s
66 67 or so at IBM he began working on
cryptography again and recycled a whole
lot of the early stuff from 20 years
before and produced first the output of
that the important out but there are two
things as a system commonly called
Lucifer it's not clear what its formal
name is it went is a component of
something called the IBM 2984 it's a
32-bit system with a 64-bit key and it
was used in banking and when 1975 data
encryption standard was proposed
it's a 64-bit block system with a 56 bit
key and it was adopted two years later
and the further layer system was
replaced and most of the IBM equipment
and that system became very important
and that system was the center of a
fight for which I am very grateful one
of the yuppies
yippy is said don't speak ill of the
police the police legitimized the
demonstration and that was kind of hard
there was a big fight that started over
on Ross Road due to Paul Baran who's the
true inventor of the Internet he was the
host and among other things Oh number of
I Triple E topics on the table but one
one was added about about whether to
take a position on DES which was then a
year or so the proposal was a year or so
and suddenly the meaning was enhanced
previously the longest travelling person
came from LA suddenly three guys showed
up from Washington and they were Denny
Branstad whom some of you probably know
you may not know the other two or Doug
Hogan who has died and Arthur Levinson
who was a great shining light at at NSA
he worked at Bletchley Park
he went around the continent collecting
Brit collecting German cryptographic
equipment and some cryptographers after
the war things like that at any event
there started at that meeting and
argument and I've been as I'm very
grateful I'm making a living off this
argument for 40 years now this spring
Marty had I had proposed I said you know
56 bits that's not enough that's just a
billion billion
I did some counting you know with this
it's possible to break not say it's
cheap I had probably too high in essence
possible to break it
you shouldn't adopt anything you think
it's possible to break and Marty worked
on this and he cooked this estimate down
he wrote a paper mostly him about how it
can be done in silicon on sapphire which
has been forgotten and I don't remember
whether it was Seymour also bipolar or
what but didn't even got at the cost
estimate bound about 20 million bucks to
do it in a day which may be a little
optimistic for that period um and Arthur
Levinson Arthur Levinson was really
sarcastic about his design yeah I've got
to see the basic thing here this is a
artha Levinson's of Brooklyn boy Marty
Hellman he's a Bronx boy you know talk
you know one doesn't talk to the other
this way so we got you know this fight
went on for a while we lost it in a
tactical sense I can't figure out now
whether we were right or not I mean des
what's called single des that system was
in stayed in use till 1991 I think it's
the first time it began to be much be
modified eventually by tooth by going on
to 2000 it was quote triple des you do
it three times in a row with either two
or three different keys
and you know it's not actually again
still in use of course nothing ever goes
away in cryptography I mean almost
guarantee you somebody used an enigma
machine in anger in the world in the
last 24 hours
I don't know who it was right but I
think there's a good chance of that the
last I mean the last enigma problem and
si will admit to having worked was
against the Stasi in about 1960 early
sixties so thing the signatures go on
and somebody haven't there's some really
dreadful machine from the 20s and
somebody was still selling it a few
years ago Manson yeah got this kind of
thing so um in the late 90s
National Bureau of National Institute
for Standards and Technology were then
undertook another development of a
symmetric algorithm in cryptography gave
it a wonderful name you know where we
hire these guys the advanced encryption
standard and but they did it the right
way they did by an international contest
right there was a set of requirements a
bunch of hurdles you had to jump to keep
you from just sitting down for one
evening and scribbling something down
and setting it in they accepted 15
submissions they stood over them for
about two years with three international
kind conferences and criticism by the
public community 30 NSA people came to
the first conference fewer came to the
later conferences and si assigned both
COMSEC people and SIGINT people to it so
it's pre before its release I don't know
if it's the most carefully evaluated
system of all time
but it's got the most pre-release
evaluation of a new system and it was
signed by the Secretary of Commerce in
November 2001 and is still in use and
will be in use you know on my ass
tonight for an indefinite period of time
and as I say it's a vastly you know a
vastly refined version of the things
whose principles were sat down in 1500
well now i've skipped over the part that
brought me here right the most sensitive
operation in all crypto security is key
management if you can starts with the
manufacture of keys if you can
manufacture good keys you can have
secure cryptography you might have to
manufacture a lot of key you use what's
called one-time material you print giant
books of it you tear out the pages and
incinerate them and all that but it is
logically possible to have secure
cryptography if you can make secure keys
and if you can't there is no possibility
of it and there are some real breaks in
our own literature in the early nineties
SSL from certain machines was broken
because you could predict the random
numbers that the client was going to
produce
server was usually somewhat better than
that so then what you do with the keys
well if you're a tightly integrated
organization like the DoD then there's
something you can do because DoD is
interesting DoD is a rather large
organization has more than a million
employees but everybody knows the chain
of command goes to the president of the
Secretary of Defense soldier to the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs to the four
stars you know and on down to people's
with rifles and in foxholes that gives
it the blessing of being able to appoint
quote the executive agent for
communication security that of course is
NSA so you have this huge organization
the church is trust a small part of a
smaller organization to manufacture all
the
material and ship it out to everybody
now if you think about the internet
that's just absolutely a non-starter
there is nobody maybe nobody anybody
trusts but nobody that everybody trusts
on the internet because all classic
military networks are meant to friends
to talk to each other look at something
young modern like super net secret
Internet Protocol router network that's
it's all people have secret clearances
who operated cleared facilities and
operate approved terminals all of that
but the Internet is meant for everybody
to talk to everybody else and
consequently you can't have any one
agent to to do this sort of thing and
you would really you know your your
prospects should be very limited if you
had to do it that way and that's so
that's what led me and me and Marty and
independently Ralph Merkle and
independent listen people at GCHQ to
think about this problem of how do you
arrange you know you and I want to talk
how do we arrange common keys or the
other problem and I because I mean I
don't think well I think God makes this
up as we go along right I've been
thinking about two problems I began
thinking about how you arrange key is in
1965 because some friend of mine told me
that the NSA encrypted the telephones
inside its own building and I was too
anti societal to understand you know
from an organizational point of view it
would do perfectly fine to go around you
know you'd improve things by go around
plugging keys into the phones whole
building everybody has top-secret
clearances anyway it would mean that
somebody were able to intercept the
traffic for some reason they'd have a
lot of trouble reading it but my notion
of a secure phone call was you know you
call somebody and you can understand it
and they can understand it nobody else
in the world could possibly understand
it so the notion that somebody would
have manufactured the key and delivered
it to you that that was just a
non-starter in my view
1970 I got to Stanford and John McCarthy
went off to a conference in Bordeaux and
talked about Internet commerce I didn't
call it that then he called it buying
and selling through home terminals he
had in mind something like what a mensch
when you emerged in France a few years
later as the Minitel but I got me
thinking about automated offices in my
house now what do you do for the
signature in an automated office because
signatures on paper depend on their
uniqueness it's very hard to reproduce
one but digital documents can be copied
bit for bit exactly so I've been
worrying about two problems when in 1975
I found the answer to two of them in one
one package and this is what we call
public key cryptography the the then of
course the solution diversifies out
around the problems and some things do
key negotiation better some things do
signature better etc but that is what
gave rise fundamentally those arguing
about des but we've moved now and I'll
get back to this into an era of arguing
you know what do you do if you have
really secure secure cryptography
because a lot of people in society you
think they're entitled to spy on
everybody
and that's only going to get worse so
let's see what I get to next okay so let
me just describe the pre battles briefly
about this in starting essentially
without work and said that's to some
extent also with feistel and IBM's work
in the 70s NSA suddenly had a rude shock
of exactly the kind that anybody thinks
he owns a market has what this is our
market what a lot of people do is they
are supposed to be here right and it
began trying to it had one set of laws
that was very significant that affected
this that's export control export
control was designed post-world War two
it's applications of cryptography
combination of law and regulation was
written in the late forties when one
the US was a good first of the world's
economy it had went you know either
blowing up the rest of the world's
economy to lent the money to other
people to blow it up so we were a very
large part of the manufacturing in the
world to cryptography was a very small
part of commercial activity all
companies used to the bitten banks used
a bit and not know it wasn't that as far
as I was if when I got into this field
soup in 1970 those were the main users
and so there was no great inconvenience
to American companies when they couldn't
export cryptography didn't make much of
it anyway
once it began to become important that
of course was a very useful tool for the
government in limiting commercial
production of cryptography the they
tried they didn't like then then this
Hauer then just dislike cryptographic
production they didn't like
cryptographic publication so what people
usually don't ignore people what Marty
calls first crypto war is about the
right to study and publish and develop
cryptography in the public world and
that one was sort of one the only real
obvious battle is in 1980 Bobby Inman
who was head of NSA appointed a group
from the American is American Committee
on education who invent between
education who was supposed to bring back
a report favorables is getting a law
kind of like the Atomic Energy Act which
would declare that cryptographic facts
were born secret so when the the group
produced a very negative report with an
even more negative dissenting opinion
and that was the end of that the mid 70s
NSA tried to capture on the market in
another way and I actually think had a
wonderful conversation with a childhood
friend of Marty's also in this business
I don't see here is he Tom bearson
in the mid 70s mid 70s mid 80s and I
said to him basically I didn't see how
we could win against an organization
that was willing to misuse its
regulatory authority in support of its
marketing it had introduced what we call
type 2 crypto systems which weren't good
enough for classified traffic we're
going to were leged lis going to made
more widely available etc Tom looked off
into space he said I don't think they
know much about marketing and 30 years
has proven him correct but they they
they they expanded the only sort of
really visible thing came out of that
the program calls 2-3 which produced
half a million loosely speaking secure
telephones which was the first the
government had significantly had secure
telephones and it's very interesting
what happened to that I mean the things
those were their immediate descendants
still exists the critical point was in
the mid 80s office communication was a
telephone a fax ran over a telephone a
modem
ran over a telephone right and so if you
could secure your telephone you had your
hands on the wasp waste of the problem
that solution stayed perfectly valid
it's merely that communication
diversified itself out around the
solution so by 2000 or so suddenly you
know all these pagers and mobile phones
and Ethernet and satellite
communications and so forth now it's a
lot harder to do one thing particularly
if you want to keep it secret so the the
thing that would snake solve would solve
a lot of the problem is to get it into
the mobile telephone standards and there
is some crypto in the mobile telephone
standards but not really the right thing
so if there was some region of a chip
that kept getting smaller and smaller
that went into Motorola phones and Nokia
phones and Apple phones and so forth
that would be good from a security point
of view that is not entirely congenial
to everybody and that they try they've
done it in other ways but it's cost them
a great deal more money so the the
second crypto war shaped up in the 90s
and it consisted of two pieces one is
the fight over at export control and the
other is the fight of something called
key escrow and both of at least latter
one particularly is back key escrow was
the notion the government had the right
to read your traffic so it adopted a
federal standard really strange federal
standard most federal standards say you
know either do this and get the
following measurements or do that like
des do this exactly this way and it will
conform to the standard this standard
said if we like you maybe we'll sell you
equipment call this number and that that
limped along for a while and eventually
they Declassified the cryptographic
algorithm used but by then the smell was
so bad there nobody know a very nice
algorithm called skip tack but nobody
much was willing to use it and that the
critical thing was export control and
that collapsed basically because in 2000
a report was written for the European
community totally analysis of what's
happening now written by a man named
Duncan Campbell on Commission to the
European Parliament who reported on a
variety of snooping programs my my
senility is getting to me again I forget
the mayor s Ilan Ashwin's right which is
a scheme for sort of separating the
sources of material from the
characteristics of materials so you get
it off the sources and then you shuffle
it to the customers um
and that piss the Europeans off decided
the Yanks were spying on them so
suddenly they wanted to control
cryptography less because they weren't
secure Europe better that put us
manufacturers as a big disadvantage and
the government was under a lot of
pressure to let us export stuff and the
export control regulations were were
relaxed dramatically and I think
basically rather cleverly the the
problem then didn't recur until these
last five years and both elements are
would have occurred thanks to Edward
Snowden we have some solid data on who's
snooping on whom and thanks to the FBI
we have a loud demand that it ought to
be able to spy on any piece of equipment
and these problems are not going to stay
one we may win again this time but this
fight was just go on indefinitely
because the the most you know there's no
more important fact about the president
than we are doing something we have not
done in 5,000 years 5,000 years ago we
moved into cities and so the first time
people lived in an environment designed
by people and what had been natural law
became matters of human policy and now
we're moving our civilization into into
cyber channels and therefore things that
were natural law are now matters of
policy so of course we're gonna go
fighting about the policy well I've now
managed to you know like the professor
so go really slowly at the beginning of
the term and then they get to the hard
material and they speed up now I've
managed to drag on for a while telling
you how we got to where we are let me
say a little bit about where we are
what's going on because the most obvious
question all of the image you know be
cryptography prior to something I'll get
to had succeeded if when I would say you
know going from 1915 or so arguable day
to the very first rotor machine to 2005
the adoption of something called sweet B
of cryptographic algorithms by NSA suite
a were presumably from secret ones sweet
B set of public algorithms they're all
in this standards publications that are
trusted for all levels of classified
traffic and they forcefully sold them
around the world we'll get back to that
point as well and began to adopt them
and so in a vague sense you know we had
propeller furs did the same thing that
some foolish wolf hound didn't
Ireland a couple of centuries ago right
some some were found killed the last
wolf that was really bad for job
prospects among wolf islands and so yeah
I ran into Dickie George who's the
highest placed defensive guy at NSA at
the time at the RSA Conference he says
you and I added now with a job I was
chief security officer at Sun
Microsystems and I was concerned with
security in the product line he was
concerned with security and NSA's
product line says do you still do any
cryptography I said oh yes as much as I
can possibly justify he looked you know
look dreamy said yeah me too I realize
you know what we are with a bunch of old
creepy is trying to pretend we've been
recycled or some kind of cyber warriors
so we look relevant the trouble is I
mean so cryptography cryptographic
algorithms look great everything from
cryptographic implementation to
operating systems hypervisors to happes
look dreadful
and so the basically we've moved into a
codependence with the with the
anti-malware people the basic problem of
computer security was set out about 1970
it's called the confinement problem I
think it all the the structure ought to
be called a Soraka surahs' cos is the
journey of the Russian word for a prison
laboratory it's what Solzhenitsyn was in
1949 about which he wrote first circle
now those guys were denied with
developing secure voice for Stalin
it's called secret telephony and he was
going to shoot him if they didn't
deliver it in six months in 1949 they
actually did deliver something those
systems so systems are violently still
on the air but um the
the confinement problem is that you want
to run a piece of software you want you
know maybe you can't guarantee you get
useful work out of it you want to
guarantee it can't hurt you and all of
the early said we had this fantasy which
is I think partly for good reasons and
partly for very bad reasons not been
realized which was you'd have a small
part of the computer it was called the
reference monitor and it would be
implemented in a little thing called the
security kernel and it would be proven
correct by formal mathematical methods
it turned out that proving things
correct was a great deal more difficult
probably a factor of a thousand Peter
back there may know better than I do but
essentially what's been possible there
are it won the skill base of people who
can do it as small and the amount of it
you can do is not terribly large and so
the best people can do is demand the
sent you the samples or some of the most
sensitive code in systems be proven
correct so we now have billions of lines
of code and no obvious prospect
environment how is how we're going to
make them secure and if sort of given up
on the what I consider the first line
issue of organizing them so they're
secure the second thing about this
however is the assets have expanded
tremendously so if you think of an old
time sharing machine signal for a single
program counter single memory path etc
running a bunch of people's jobs
you can't consume you can't conceal
anything from anybody else it's like a
bunch of immigrants you know nine of
them living in the same room they can't
avoid undressing in front of each other
they enough next generation they spread
out to nine apartments they have some
privacy
well when everybody is in the same one
queue you can hammer on the Run queue
and signal to people turns out thousands
of bits a second
but you get to the point where you can
allocate one processor per process right
then you're a much better position and
that is possibly the foundational
technique should be the foundational
technique of everything we do but it
isn't and it takes a while to explain
you know efficiency has been pushed
ahead of security in that direction you
have you have multiple processors which
are various levels of shared caches you
probably don't have enough processors
and so instead we've turned to a whole
bunch of companies of which one comes to
my mind is fire I but I started by a
protege of mine and those companies in
produce you know virus filters or as
fire I does they run they run malware in
in isolated containers but the cost of
the containers is too high for it just
to be part of normal software and we're
not doing so well I think a lot of the
problem and I really know what to do
about this is that everybody it isn't
just the government's the companies want
their customers to be secure against
everybody with them and it's not really
clear what the alternative is that is
saying you know I'm not a good enough
sis it men to mentor in some way and
manage by hand the updates to my
computer and look at the proposed
updates and see if they're worth
installing and audit them to see if they
were correctly installed and all of the
rest and if you have the authority to
install the updates then you can install
one that there's a keyboard logger bug
somebody and as I say even and even if
you remain the best you can do that I
can see that's not terribly difficult is
and I think the pub the open source
people do a good build of this is you
have a public bulletin board and you can
see that what you downloaded is exactly
the same thing that was available to a
bunch of other people as opposed to
Apple calls me and sends me something
how am I supposed to know what they sent
him
and but even so of course it's probably
formally undecidable whether the update
contains the serial number of my
computer and as you know update of fix
everybody but him screw him and I happen
to what I haven't I haven't think
exemplary as something happened now five
years ago I'll say security or you know
one of the foremost security companies
they make this little widget really I've
been saying it was a dumb widget for
thirty years and they've been making
money off it for 30 years so who's dumb
a little widget
you know exhibits a transient password
and you type that in along with a
longer-term password and there are two
errors involved if somebody got a
spreadsheet with a misleading name some
combination of apparently came from
internally and was was sexy it might
tell him his boss's salary or something
of that kind
so opens a spreadsheet and in fact wait
did his guy in by the throat captures
his machine captured the network and now
we come to the next big error these
idiots who manufacture and sell keying
material for a living had it floating
free in the network I mean by comparison
right NSA it's moved but it had a hole
in Finksburg Maryland fifty feet deep
and that hole manufactured key and oh
the only NSA people could not freely go
into that hole except to the fifty who
worked there so this you you must
restrict key very carefully and RSA
didn't do it at that time um somebody at
NSA told me I told sense somebody at NSA
I presume you manufactured your own key
for the for the RSA witnesses and no I
don't think so I think we got it from
there I I found that very surprising
because they're so proud of their
ability to manufacture key I somebody
failed if they didn't see there was
another market into which they can sell
keys so to speak
um so now I said you know cryptic I
think I was doing pretty well
well that was it's actually been a
in that armor and a in that armor
and here we get back to the point of NSA
boy they don't know how to do marketing
NSA for a decade and a half now has been
marketing the suite b of public
algorithms to all of its various
partners in France last summer it comes
out with an announcement and yeah I know
who wrote this it's Trump asked and it's
Impala tech quality it says well if
you've implemented Suite B thank you
very much we really appreciate that
but if you didn't maybe you shouldn't
bother because we're going to have to
come out with new quantum computing
resistance algorithms now now let's go
at some point you might have to say that
you know and of course it's possible and
if they know something they haven't told
me it does happen from time to time but
as far as I can tell
neither wean the public community nor
they you know know what to do about
quantum resistant algorithms all of the
things I know about that are candidates
and the three basic schemes of whole
lattice systems coding based systems Mac
Elise type systems and knapsacks all
have gigantic keys I mean the millions
of bits rather than the hundreds of bits
and that means the whole architecture of
things is going to have to be changed it
seems very unlikely if the problem is
solved
that will be followed by something of
anything of comparable efficiency to
what we do at the moment and so we're
gonna have to go back to caching keys if
you look at secure phones the ice
mentioned this to three its precise of
this to two you had to make a phone call
to a key distribution center every time
you got a key
and so they cache it for a day or so in
case you call the same person again
which lots of bureaucrats you know call
the same
over and over again all day well now
we're going to end up I think with
something potentially like you know once
a year you have a five minute or
something communication with Amazon and
you negotiate a key that you then keep
through the rest of the year from which
you derive whatever operational Keys you
have with them but have any event this
whole business is now in a mess
NSA sort of enlarged the sizes of what
it has but nothing is clear about how
long certainly the public key component
of this going to be secure quantum
computing doesn't do very much to the
symmetric component it sort of it sort
of cuts certain sorting problems in half
so you know key if blink 256 work factor
estimated around 160 or something that's
perfectly clear all right that would be
okay on the other hand that's every
danger that the elliptic curve type
systems with keys around 350 400 bits
are going to be screwed you know this
all depends on the for from all the
physicists right from the people who
brought you the black hole who knows
what to expect cubit me is a quantum bit
it's something that simultaneously
occupies all the states between zero and
one I don't know I mean people keep
announcing that can factor the number
fifteen now I've given I don't try to
keep any careful track of how quantum
computing is going you know invite a
physicist over here to talk now the
other big thing only me let me skip
forward what was my point the big
problem has made no progress my view is
a big problem which is you know I got
into this I thought the same thing every
mathematician for several hundred years
thought when you got into cryptography
why this is a mess I'm gonna clean this
up we're going to get you know a formal
theory we're gonna have proofs of the
security of crypto systems I mean it was
bull about breaking them and so forth
well I failed completely everybody else
has failed completely the problem is
actually fairly simple in a certain
sense the problem is fairly simple this
is a problem of proving lower balance
and complexity of certain computations
well there were lower about solid lower
bounds on easy computations like
addition done Winston was a IBM someone
there are lower bounds on some very very
difficult problems but they're too
difficult to be cryptographic problems
because a cryptographic system cannot be
more than np-hard if you if you know the
key if you found the answer then you
need to be able to verify it very
quickly because you've got to be able to
to encrypt very quickly right so the
complexity problem that we have is
exactly in this PNP range that has
resisted resisted work for more than 50
years now and there is lots of
theoretical computer science that claims
to be proofs about things in crypto
security and I know I just don't follow
what they're talking about so to speak
they're basically infinite istic models
asking asymptotic models of some kind or
other and they don't really settle down
when there's exactly 300 bits of
question what happens okay however the
sexier topics are I've mentioned quantum
computing the other great thing was
discovered here by Craig Gentry a few
years ago is called homomorphic
encryption and this is this is a
beautiful piece of magic the notion is I
like somewhat extravagant examples but
you know 40 years ago nearly there was
this rumor doesn't make any sense does
this rumor that Soviet agents operating
out of some laboratory in Vienna forgot
it was we're stealing time off the
cray-1 at York at
Warwick and running and running nuclear
hydro codes I'm a little skeptical of
this as a friend of mine Sandia said
anytime they want to send those codes
and those data down here we'll be happy
to run the point of our best machines
but maybe you know I mean but yes these
days these days it is possible to steal
computing time on machines fairly
profitable now it would be much better
of course if you didn't have to reveal
to the Machine what you were trying to
compute so the fantasy of homomorphic
compute hands it's been done for real in
one important case I've asked years you
encrypt the data that you want computer
on and you sent her to a computer that
can't understand what it is but they can
compute on it and it sits and thinks and
computes for a while and then it sends
you back the result which you can't
understand and you couldn't have done
the computation but you can decrypt the
result you can understand it now that
I'm drew Dean when he went to DARPA I
thought with a combination of good luck
and brilliance applied this for the most
wonderful case and there's a classic
comset problem called black conference
bridge you have a bunch of secure phones
that can talk to each other in pairs
quite attractively but of course you
want to hold a conference so the classic
way to do that is you have what's called
a red conference bridge you have
encrypted lines that run to the to the
conference bridge and the conference
bridge is sitting you know inside the
secured facility and it does all of the
mixing and adding up a boy streams and
things like that and reradiates it out
to the people talking and that has some
clear disadvantage it was a graph to
have such a trusted facility drew Dean
managed to implement a demonstration
that used Apple of iPhone 5s and Amazon
AWS computing and did the black
conference bridge in Amazon computing
with the conference held among the
people with the with the iPhone wise now
it can by no means be applied to every
problem but that's a real problem
I assume somebody's gonna productize
that as would really be worthwhile
there was a at any event that has proved
to be it's it's tantalizingly out of
rich each it's infinitely better than it
might have been it's nowhere close to
being able you know there are two kinds
of problems in general I mean me know
there's not quite close to your being
able to save money doing your nuclear
bomb design this way as opposed to
buying more computers but the certain
specialized problems like that it works
but there's a particular type of
specialized problem called private
information retrieval that works like
this you know DHS is looking for a spy
in Las Vegas
DHS ghost Las Vegas and sensitive the
hotels give us all your records we want
to look for a spy and say you know have
dinner with the king we you know what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas
we aren't giving you our records give us
the criteria will run your now we can't
give you the criteria that I tell you
are classified so the idea is we have
some scheme that specialized in this
particular case that allows some set of
computers to run on the data from the
hotels and on the stuff from from DHS
and you know neither one can figure out
the nobody can figure out the other
people's stuff um I don't know how
that's going but I have an idea if you
want to submit a paper or conference I
have an idea of so to speak the most
marketable paper that one could possibly
write at this moment there various
variations one is the simplest form
seems to me no homomorphic crypto system
could be quantum computing resistant I
have no idea well that's true I how to
prove such a result right but but I mean
you very got you know the two sexiest
topics in modern run together so I I
don't know how long this runs but my
voice is running out so okay well I'll
I'll ask for another ten questions and
since I won't understand the questions
I'll make up
oh yeah please yeah I think I'll do
people by how I like that loop looks
mark up there what can you tell us about
the history of permission permissive
action links Oh last lesson is in print
a permissive action link is a device
used to control the nuclear weapon and
the original ones were symmetric keyed
the object is to you loosely speaking
have cryptographic devices inside the
nuclear weapon which is quite tamper
resistant for a variety of reasons and
has a luxurious environment in which to
be transfer resistant because I have
power available internally razzle all
these radioactive things you can take
power off of them just incidentally I
mean there's a lot of if you want to
know what an h-bomb does when it decides
it's been tampered with
right you might really well you might
ask um and the answer the answer I was
given by somebody I believe knows things
was the military safety requirement is
the response must not propagate outside
the weapons case so the requirements of
one it disables itself so can no longer
be used in its intended mode it disables
itself to so that no longer will go off
as a nuclear device and then beyond
behind that or concealing design
criteria and things of that kind
it's dismantled internally with shaped
charges I believe the main techniques
there are the idea is that all of the
cryptographic stuff used involved in
arming the weapon is internal to a
Stamper resistant shell and then the
permissive action link sends encrypted
messages to that the greatest compliment
I've ever been paid in certain ways by a
guy named Augusto vez de Simmons and he
was flying to Australia to lecture on
nuclear command and control when he read
the August 1977 article by Martin
Gardner about public key cryptography
and he changed his lectures I thought
now
that about that's like anyway sometime
later than that they will modify he did
a huge amount of work at Sandia on
public key stuff and they were changed
to be public key and I don't know
anything about them but I may not be
because it's secret it made us beans I
haven't saved it Sun power he asked them
Scott McNealy who's my old boss of
weather epsilon that spying system was
Sun powered and I think the answer is in
Niki something's book secret power
there's a beautiful I think he actually
has a picture in it
they took through a window of some place
in Australia New Zealand that's showing
Sun Sun equipment
oh and late friend of Mines man si did
some very neat insider trading and
walked through this office every morning
go by a loading dock and see how many
sons were piled up on the loading dock
so he went bought Sun Microsystems and
he made a good deal of money
you know we unfortunately got absorbed
by Oracle before we got into the arrow
solar power
ok so we're in the midst of a third
crypto war senators Burr and Feinstein
have introduced this legislation which
they're just waiting for the next
terrorist attack so that they in it
don't have a terrorist attack if I have
to commit it themselves and they think
they will pass which provides that every
device ok has to be a have a backdoor
hiyee
it's it's it's key escrow for
billions of devices and now the question
is who holds all those key escrows and
if you look at the current set of
candidates for president the United
States you might worry about who has
control of US surveillance capability to
worry more about than the football the
nuclear codes and this event this guy
has a really great he has something it
may fall short as a business plan but
like me is very frightening and that the
that what they want is the power not
just to decrypt things but to get root
access to every device thereby they
could bypass you know the your apps run
at the at the at the courtesy of the
route and so you can't have an addition
have your own encryption running in and
AB securely very very interesting idea I
thought well you know I'm sorry no it
was not your ID you he reports it not as
his idea it's as somebody's idea but you
know it's the way I reacted there's a
book about Pearl Harbor in 1967 that
said that that purple was made out of
steppin telephone stepping switches well
that idea is too smart for a Reno for a
an intelligence writer to have thought
up that had that has to be do it turned
out it was true keeping secrets from
someone who can read your mind
alright now that that's that's going to
become over
I believe mind-reading is going to come
along quite quickly in computer there
are nice out for a second didn't say you
know I think you're far from safe from
having your mind read people can already
tell whether things your thing you they
show you pictures and then tell whether
the pictures were familiar or not and I
think that kind of thing is going to get
better and better and then I think if
certain people become president we have
the distinct possibility of bringing
three things together I've never heard
of brought together one is some kind of
mind reader reading one and one is
torture so you basically you want to
torture them and read their minds and
Owen drugs alright so you can you know
some combination of lie detector and
drugs and torture and I'll bet they'll
be working on this wholesale
so no answer there is a project for
brain implants yes
force allegedly implausibly very very
good purposes they've been some activity
in Europe about banning encryption
entirely I believe in England and
Germany what's gonna be the impact get
away with no they won't wanna ban the
encryption they want they want anything
they wanna have back doors the French
and the British literature back doors
you know they gripped all you want how
point of view banning what we think of a
secure encryption I mean the big my view
of this is but at the moment we only
know how to determine whether immensely
simple things are secure so it's
complicating security is sort of the
foremost sin in my book the other thing
I believe is that the u.s. critical
infrastructure particularly the electric
power grid are potentially tremendously
vulnerable to being brought down and
severely damaged by foreign attack that
would not kill a few dozen people in
nightclubs that might kill thousands or
millions of people all right so I were
organizing the expenditure of resources
that would be way at the top of my list
for getting things secured so they
couldn't be broken into and one of the
foremost requirements would be you
wouldn't go messing with things if you
think about you know this thing
diffie-hellman key exchange another
description some ways but it would have
been making a living off of for 40 years
establishes a key that only you and I
know and nobody else knows it and so if
we use that in a phone call and then we
hang up and the key goes away the
accounting is very simple we firmly
believe that the call was not recorded
either either end there's no other
record of it if you quote escrow the
call now the complexity of analyzing
what the actual security is is
tremendous because you don't know
whether or not it went somewhere else
it's lunch like the difference
end-to-end encryption has the advantage
you don't have to audit all the wires
from one place to another
now auditing the wires is fine it's
they're all in one building that's
that's a reasonable technique but they
go from here to Hong Kong it's a very
dubious idea large buildings no auditing
all the wires are started I sort of
believe actually all right I think they
have secure phone closets at NSA but
then for all I know they only have two I
don't know the answer I you know I I
don't know whether it's true I mean it
sounds like the kind of thing somebody
might say because Selfridge died about
three years ago so suitable time to I
create a lot of things to people who
died messages don't die or you're gonna
turn out to be the person who taught me
all this stuff they weren't supposed to
tell me no I don't I do not know the
answer the given what Selfridge was
doing but that time of his life I don't
know why shoulda known any of that he
was that late um now maybe some people's
David Costabile life as far as I know I
spoke to him three or four months ago
it has stroke last summer I visited him
in the fall he was you know perfectly
reasonably lucid but at the time he was
in a wheelchair and had 24 hour day
attendant so I I don't know why they
called him and spoke to him a little
while ago but
well you guys have Assamese lives on he
lives on on 42nd Street Oh baby the end
questions men will ask the last question
with errors a lot of scheming has
Britain proposed as a scheme as quantum
resistant as reasonably small Keys has
forward security had megabit public
kingston was a seed to generate the big
matrix so that that makes I think we
should ask an expert
yeah you just nodded yes so so it may
well be another oceanography and the
same well-known expert said to me a
little slightly complaining voice the
last conference on Monday the
cryptography is solved and it's a bit
sad and now it's a question of
engineering the systems and doing the
social engineering of the public keys
those are the unsolved it's not Mack
Alicia said this to somebody else you
know close with this
hi Robbie who's a very well-known 20th
century physicists said when he lectured
at MIT when I was a freshman that now I
forgot he studied possibly Schrodinger
awesome and he said as a graduate
student as advisor told him that all all
the big problems in physics have been
solved
Dirac had found the equation for the
electron we'd have the equation for the
proton shortly and there would be
nothing left but the mopping up and the
mopping up has taken awhile
you